I told you yesterday that coronavirus is
spiking in many parts of the country and
we also talked on the bonus show I guess
it was it was either 2 days ago or six
months ago I don't know everything feels
the same it was sometime this week about
how Donald Trump has decided that it is
time to restart huge campaign rallies
massive crowds gathered together
spreading the virus yelling about how
great Donald Trump is and now even more
cartoonishly Donald Trump's first rally
is going to be in Tulsa Oklahoma on June
19th
also known as Juneteenth which Trump is
combining a location that was the site
of a massive racist massacre with a very
important day June 19th is the
anniversary of the Emancipation the
freeing of the last enslaved African
Americans in the Confederacy in federer
see somehow it's 2020 but a big topic
this week Tulsa in 1921 was the location
of a huge racist massacre where mobs of
white people destroyed a predominantly
black Drizzt district called Greenwood
which was called Black Wall Street and
there are a number of different
questions here one is how calculated is
the date and location
Juneteenth in Tulsa Oklahoma by Donald
Trump I think Trump probably knows very
very little about this history but
certainly people like Stephen Miller and
others around Trump probably know more
about this history and to some degree I
think they get off on doing this type of
stuff now the broader public health
question is why is this happening in
Oklahoma at all and the reason is that
Oklahoma starting to allow large events
as part of their coronavirus reopening
do the numbers support this decision in
Oklahoma not really I mean if you look
at the data we're looking at case
numbers Oklahoma is not hugely spiking
it's not really improving though they
have had a pretty steady trickle of
cases for the last three months but
since the start of June Oklahoma has had
its highest three-day average of cases
it is difficult to imagine anyway that a
huge rally
if masks are not required is not going
to lead to a spike in cases now it might
not be huge but there's going to be more
contagion because of a huge rally like
this but it just doesn't matter to the
President or to the administration or to
his campaign they've decided as a
practical matter that coronavirus is
over it's time to rally that's it
there's no more press briefings there's
barely any discussion of coronavirus
they don't talk about deaths they don't
talk about cases other than to lie and
say how great they are now it is not
just Tulsa Oklahoma that Donald Trump
will be going to Donald Trump will be
holding rallies in Florida Arizona and
North Carolina and those are not maybe
it's okay maybe it's not those are
epicenters of disease right now you have
to see this to believe it
these are case growth curves that
absolutely do not suggest that you
should be having huge rallies in these
states especially with people remember
right-wingers are much more likely than
left wingers not to take the virus
seriously not to stay home not to wear
masks not to do the things you need to
do to prevent spreading it and by that
we are likely to see even more spread so
in North Carolina cases have been
steadily increasing and rising North
Carolina does not appear to have peaked
yet it's getting worse and worse and
worse in North Carolina as the days go
by Florida as I told you yesterday had a
dip in cases in late April but that
might have been when they were just
lying about the numbers they have again
peaked with new record case numbers
coming in the first part of June so far
that's not where you want to be doing
huge rallies and then you've got Arizona
Arizona maybe with the worst trendline
of any of these states cases were sort
of low in Arizona for months slow
increase and since the start of June
just a massive spike to cases in Arizona
Arizona is close to one of the worst
places in the country where you should
be having a mass rally there in danger
of running out of ICU beds all of a
sudden and that's where Donald Trump
wants to go spoke to a friend who lives
in Arizona this morning
told me that no one's wearing masks
unless it's absolutely required and that
it's not really required almost anywhere
even most indoor places and the nursing
homes are having a real real issue in
Arizona it's almost like Trump's
choosing the worst places and this could
work to get coronavirus to some rural
communities we've been talking a lot
about you know coronavirus has been
centered around cities because that's
where you have more people cities tend
to have more direct flights to China and
to Europe that made it early epicenters
were likely going to be in cities rural
folks will come to Tulsa Oklahoma
they'll come to you know Phoenix or
wherever and then they'll bring the
virus back out to rural areas people
there will get the virus but those rural
areas have a far lower hospital capacity
and dramatically lower ICU capacity and
you can imagine the way it's all going
to go now meanwhile just to show you
that things can be handled properly take
a look at Switzerland's curve
Switzerland has had under 100 new cases
per day since five weeks ago very few
deaths it's just one example it can be
done look at you know look at Iceland
look at there's so many different
examples we'll get of course Taiwan but
you really need competent leadership you
need fewer really dumb people and
unfortunately here in the United States
we lack leadership and I mean let's face
it we have a lot of ignorance we have a
lot of ignorance and that is a bad
combination I want to remind you that
Tuesday we are doing something nice to
build community so much news is negative
these days we are having the second
david pakman show chess tournament I
will be playing in the tournament I want
you to play in it all skill levels are
welcome it's free this is just totally
free we're just running this for
community sake it will be on the website
elite chess org that's li chess dot
o-r-g you can sign up on the website now
I will be tweeting out the link to the
tournament probably 7:45 p.m. Eastern on
Tuesday the 16th the tournament will
start at 8:00 and it will run somewhere
around 75 to 90 min
so make sure you are I hope you
participated we had 500 people play last
time I would love to double it if
possible also remember you can follow me
on Twitter at D Pakman at D Pakman on
Twitter and remember if you tend to
watch YouTube clips but you want to get
a daily podcast there's the free daily
podcast of the David Pakman show one
hour long it's on iTunes Spotify Pandora
Google Play stitcher all of these
different places you can get it there
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
[Music]
the David Pakman show
depends on your support and the easiest
way is through membership which includes
the world-famous bonus show as well as
commercial free audio and video streams
of the show just for members sign up
today at join pakman.com coupon code
saves you 40% vote soon 18 the david
pakman show at david pakman.com today's
new members of the day are Todd Sayer
and Sonia dray Todd and Sonia thank you
so much for your support and an
extra-special huge thank you to Richard
Carnes Richard has been a member at join
pakman.com for almost 5 years if you can
imagine and is today's longtime
sustaining member of the day
grab a membership at join pakman.com
coupon code available but never
mandatory the coupon code is 20/20 now
to 0 to 0 n o w and that'll save you 66%
okay let's go to the phones at 6 1 7 8 3
0 47 50 many many people waiting
anxiously to say their piece will start
today with our caller from the 3 to 3
area code who's calling today from 3 to
3
hello yes that's you two questions for
you what do you think they can do about
the Georgia delays and in the election
so corrupt there that I just I would I
would hope that you know black lives
matter would also like gather around the
Georgia City Hall and protest that
because they're just disenfranchising
people yep we talked about this earlier
in the week and if you want a preview of
the voter disenfranchisement and
election fraud tactics that we are going
to see in November just look at what
happened in Georgia
earlier this week and you know certainly
it has not been a focus of the protests
of the last ten days that that's that's
okay the protests were about something
else
but we need every nonprofit that works
on voter disenfranchisement activated we
need to overwhelm the vote by so much
that even by cheating they can't win but
if if anybody doubted and at this point
I don't know why you would if anybody
doubted what we are going to see in
November we saw it in Georgia this week
and there's no one solution it's we've
got to push for vote by mail we've got
to push for not closing polling places
prevent the voter roll purges anybody
who can vote early should anybody who
can vote by mail should but we've got to
overwhelm the vote because they're going
to try to take it with these tactics we
they do it every year and trump is extra
desperate right now yeah well that's a
strategy that's not by chance the idea
is make it harder to vote in places
where at the at the in the average
people are more likely to vote for
Democrats and you had people who vote in
overwhelmingly white precincts in
Georgia saying I don't know what people
are talking about I showed up I voted in
five minutes there was nobody there are
plenty of voting booths and everything's
fine that's the strategy yeah at the
poll said she drove she after waiting
for three hours she drove to a white
place and thought people just walking in
there wasn't even a line yep it's it's
predictable and it's horrible yeah and
then my final final comment is with the
Joe Rogan interview I love Joe Rubens
but he seems like to be using you like a
I don't know like you're his
psychologist or so because he just
talked so much more than normal you're
just like I was like David say something
I didn't know too I didn't notice that
to be perfectly frank yeah he was going
on and on and I wasn't playing Joe you
know buddy let's get talked a lot more
but he was it was like he was waiting
for you like you know I need to unload
the David coming so I could just stay
this very polite so I'm just gonna talk
and talk it's not I don't know if that
was real you know when when when
done via Skype like I wasn't in the room
with Joe it sometimes may be tougher to
read when it would be a natural time for
the other person to talk so maybe that
was a factor but in the moment I didn't
notice it it didn't seem that way right
but maybe maybe maybe because he doesn't
see you there
he feels a sort of maybe a little bit of
anxiety in order to try to fill the
moment maybe something because he
doesn't see your physical cues right
you're ready to jump in keep going and
going and going well anyway that's it
thank you so much I'm a huge fan I'm a
member you know and I recommended my
cousin to be your member and not anybody
who I talk to about in terms of like you
know getting a good news source I tell
them you know David Patten is one of the
best
thank you for he'll secular talk with
[ __ ] Alinsky yeah so you guys are
alright appreciate it thank you so much
take care great to hear from you let's
go next to our caller from the 662 area
code who's calling today from 662 hey
David yes okay just hold on one second
let's see if we can clean up the
connection a little bit are we on
speakerphone right now we are okay sorry
okay okay very good I and there was good
it seems like whatever noise was
happening in the background has been
resolved who's this where are you
calling from
this is Rossum comprehend for Colorado
great what's going on today hey a lot of
temple and he's thinking that a lot of
people are lying to the pollsters about
Biden and thinking they're just like
sitting really gonna vote for clod
there's like it's silent majority
especially with like his economic
Gribble rating is like at 58% just
wanted to know what your thoughts were
on that I haven't I mean I've not seen
this assertion made I don't I don't know
what Tim is saying I think you have to
defend such an assertion with evidence
and merely pointing to higher economic
approval
then support for Trump wouldn't really
be evidence it could just as easily be
evidence that despite feeling that
things are okay economically people
still are going to vote for Biden over
Trump like we're it's it's one of these
it's an in defeasible argument you can't
possibly make a counter point because
implicitly it's that people are not
telling the truth so if by deaf if your
argument is people or lying we wouldn't
be able to disprove that until people
actually vote in November so we kind of
have to just wait and see okay but I
think it also happened in 2016 I think
people are ashamed to say hey I'm a not
not a trump supporter by minimum in what
sense that it happened in to hold on
whatever we had that happened late 2016
what that what evidence do we have that
it it happened in 2016 oh because
everyone thought that it was gonna be a
blowout victory for Hillary I mean like
the New York Times what was it are the
Huffington Post was a 93 percent chance
he was going to win okay no but let's so
these are we're now I think this is a
good opportunity to to think about some
of these things in a couple different
ways so there are times I think said on
election day that it was like a 70%
chance that Hillary won now what you
know that when they say that they're not
predicting Hillary gets 70 percent of
the votes
a 70 percent chance to win means that if
you run a hundred elections with the
inputs we had in 70 of them Hillary
would win and in 30 Trump would win so
that part you understand right yeah okay
good so then the second part is the
polling on election day was that Hillary
was ahead nationally by 3.2 and she won
by 2.1 which is within the margin the
stated margin of error so the national
polls were were correct in 2016 okay but
I I just really think the Democrats are
playing with fire when they're talking
about defunding the police when there's
like a poll the game out that like 88
percent of people are satisfied but the
police are either want more funding and
only like 12 percent want to defund
employees right so now but so now you
you're now making a totally different
argument you're
argument was that in 2016 people lied
about supporting Hillary now you're
saying defund the police is a bad idea
you're acknowledging we're now on to
something different right yeah okay
little bit now I agree with you I'm I
think that the I don't know if you saw
my clip but the poll I saw says only 16%
of the country supports defund I think
it's the wrong messaging I've put out a
much more specific plan that is about
demilitarize and retrain and re delegate
and stuff like that so on this issue I
agree with you but on the issue that in
2016 people lied about supporting
Hillary the data don't back that up all
right maybe I'll have to look more into
it but David I appreciate your column
little bit more on the right but I do
use your show to get a more balanced
perspective and I appreciate what you do
ma'am all right thank you for the call
very much appreciate it I think
hopefully we were able to resolve a few
factual misunderstandings there I
venture to say okay let's go next to our
caller from the four four three area
code who is calling today from four four
three hey with me yes it is who's this
hi this is Alex from Maryland how you
doing David good how are you I'm doing
good um I just had a quick question for
you um if you were to update the federal
poverty levels how would you do it in a
progressive way that's interesting so
there's a couple different things the
federal poverty level in and of itself
is is potentially not a good measure
because cost of living varies so
dramatically from state to state so
federal poverty level that has to apply
to new york city and rural Wyoming is
inherently problematic because the cost
of living is so dramatically different
in those two places you know what I mean
yeah yeah so so first and foremost I
would say we would want or maybe revisit
what the federal poverty level is even
used for because it's not a good measure
for a lot of different things maybe it
should be done at the state level or
county or city that you know the problem
about city is do you do it based on
where someone lives or where someone
works you have people who
work in New York City but live in
Connecticut there's complexities but
conceptually I think that what it costs
to the living wage needs to be taken
into account when we think of the
federal poverty level and probably the
poverty level combined with whatever
social safety net benefits you would
qualify for should add together to be a
living wage like the ideal thing would
be every job pays a living wage that's a
different type of legislative apparatus
then setting the poverty level so I
think that we should be looking at a
framework where adjusted for cost of
living poverty level has to get you a
certain amount of social safety net
benefits where when combined you get to
a living wage if that makes sense and if
this is like a fantasy I mean this is
like we're nowhere even close to this
being a serious discussion yeah this is
all theoretical at this point I was just
looking up apartments around my area and
I was I saw that the federal poverty
level is still fifteen thousand dollars
and change and I thought that was
ridiculous there's no way you could live
anywhere in the US on that so if you
know if it's fifteen thousand in a lot
of places you could be making double
that and you can't afford a one-bedroom
apartment and that makes no sense which
i think is the point you're making yeah
exactly
all right David thank okay thank you I
appreciate the call yeah likewise let me
go next to our caller from the three
four seven area code who's calling today
from three four seven Oh lost my pen
here Hey yes it is hey David how are you
good eater New York hey Peter what's up
I was wondering if you could wave a
magic wand and implement any three
policies oh boy I mean I guess at the
micro level some kind of health care for
all would be would be number one number
two we would want to do campaign finance
reform because that connects to like if
you care about education or abortion or
whatever the way that elections are
financed is a huge part of of how all of
those issues are dealt with and used
this fundraising wedges so we would we
would do campaign finance reform and
that's not one law right like that's up
changing a huge apparatus so I would say
health care campaign finance and
probably something serious on climate
change because again it's going to be
hard to deal with any other issues if
the country's underwater or nobody can
breathe
so maybe most urgently I would go with
those three what do you feel about
rank-choice voting yeah ranked so that
if you said top five I would include
changing the voting system and I've
actually said before I do I'm not
necessarily married to ranked choice but
there's a few different versions
including single transferable vote and a
number of others that we've talked about
if you said what's your election reform
package it would be a combination of
getting rid of first-past-the-post
combined with campaign finance reform
and I've got a bunch of clips about rank
choice versus other systems that you can
check out yeah okay appreciate it thank
you so much we're gonna take a quick
break but we will go right back to the
phones when we get back so if you are on
hold don't hang up okay don't hang up
you've already called in you're already
on hold and we will get two more calls
right after this short break the david
pakman show at david pakman.com
[Music]
the david pakman show depends on the
support of our viewers and listeners and
one way to keep us going is through
patreon where you can pledge as little
as one dollar per month or as much as
you want at patreon.com slash david
pakman show great perks and benefits as
well read about him welcome back to the
David Pakman show ok let's take a few
more calls at 6 1 7 8 3 0 47 50 starting
with our caller from the 705 area code
who's calling today from 7:05 I think
that's me yes
yeah I'm calling from Northern Ontario
Canada great I was wondering if you
could comment on with the pandemic I've
noticed that a lot of especially more
corrupt governments are taking this time
to seize more power than they should for
example in Poland and especially in
Hungary yep Viktor Orban was given the
power to rule by decree and I was
wondering if you could comment on the
state of democracy in the u.s. I've seen
some worrying things but both by mail
and gerrymandering that seem that the
Republicans and seem to be trying to do
absolutely so I here in the United
States we have several layers of
[Music]
totalitarian ish tendencies from the
current federal government so one of the
first red flags was when coronavirus
started the Justice Department was
asking for essentially the suspension of
habeas corpus in effect where the
Justice Department wanted a situation
where if they have people being held
pretrial who normally would have a right
to a speedy trial which means the
charges against you are presented you're
you know given a lawyer a court date
that's relatively expeditious given a
chance to prepare a defense etc the
Trump Justice Department
once that suspended so that they can
just hold people indefinitely and say
listen you're not you've not been
sentenced to prison but you're not
getting bail and you're just gonna sit
in prison and the charges against you
aren't moving forward because courts are
operating at diminished capacity because
of coronavirus extremely totalitarian
very very concerning
we then saw with the protests here in
the United States Donald Trump's first
instinct when we have protests against
police brutality is to say governors
aren't being brutal enough I'm gonna
send in the the military in order to be
more brutal and to further repress
protest very very totalitarian Donald
Trump using so far using coronavirus
although I wouldn't be surprised to see
him try to use the protests as well to
justify we shouldn't vote by mail voting
by mail leads to fraud we shouldn't do
it it's just a voter suppression tactic
Trump insists Democrats can only win if
they cheat well it's clear he thinks he
needs to cheat in order to win or at
least suppress the vote so it's very
very disturbing what we're seeing here
before all of this started the United
States and the democracy index was
ranked a flawed democracy and the state
of democracy here is dramatically
declining earlier this week in Georgia
we had huge voter suppression and
strategically left-leaning and non-white
areas I mean it's it's ugly it's very
very ugly yeah that's I think that is
really concerning um one thing I was
going to ask is do you think that with I
don't really understand it because you
know I don't I don't live down there but
I from what I understand it's with
vote-by-mail and stuff like that that's
in the care of the the state secretary
is it the Attorney General or the
secretary say there's someone down there
an elected official who controls that is
I think semi independent of the state
legislatures the secretary well it's
it's it's independent of the legislature
but these are elected positions I
believe in just about every state the
Secretary of State and we've had crazy
situations where like in 2018 Brian Kemp
was Secretary of State in Georgia and he
was candidate for governor
lo and behold his overseeing of his own
race for governor led to him becoming
governor in Georgia among widespread
allegations of voter suppression listen
I'm gonna have to let you go because
your connection is a bit problematic and
it's coming in a little bit crunchy but
very very important issues and I'm glad
you're paying attention to them let's go
next to our caller from the 6-5 zero
area code who's calling today from six
five zero
yes hello that me yes it is I was mostly
calling to talk a little bit about the
alternatives or to the sort of policing
system and we have we're talking about
defunding the police right and it doing
so do you believe that that would maybe
create a lot more informal conflict
resolution that would occur like
naturally in communities sort of rely on
that because I know that in more
developing countries they sort of run
into this problem where you know crimes
are committed constantly but people
don't have old many criminal histories
officially because the police just
aren't involved in a lot of criminal
aspects things like that right and how
that works and in terms of doing so that
gives like a lot of employers and a
little bit of autonomy a lot of
confidence to think highly trusts things
like that it's tended to be a big a
social fabric and I just want to see if
you speak about that yeah an informal
conflict resolution can be good or bad
depending on the context right you do
have places where things like burglaries
or or physical crimes are dealt with by
families or groups or mob like entities
essentially dealing with it by
themselves and I don't know that that's
really any better than having police
involvement in other cases for other
types of disputes you can certainly
support infrastructure for resolution
that doesn't involve police but what is
important to understand is a lot of
these conflicts I guess is the word
we're using a lot of these conflicts
aren't really resolved
by police in the sense that police may
be involved initially but really it's
the court system that ultimately is
adjudicating right either through plea
deals state's attorneys and prosecutors
etc so I think it's also important when
we think about you know defund versus
reform and we've already I've already
had that conversation a bunch of times
this week we also want to not pretend
that the police are more involved in the
resolution of a lot of these things now
because really the police you know in a
burglary police are showing up and
they're eventually it's assigned to a
detective and an investigation is done
but eventually really the resolution and
the disposition is determined by the
court system and that's a different
system it's part of a broader law
enforcement apparatus in a sense but
it's a different system so I think it's
important we don't want to overstate or
understate where police are and are not
involved if that makes sense
no question okay all right appreciate
the call thank you so much let's go next
to our caller from the 9:08 area code
who's calling today from 9:08 hi is this
me yes it is who's this Oh
my name is furry huh I'm from New Jersey
so it's like such a pleasure to be able
to talk to you I really love your shop
and like a year now wow thank you the
pleasure is mine yeah um I guess like I
has a very general broad question for
you sure and I wanted to know what um
sorry I just want to know what we're the
biggest inspiration for like your
progressive out look like regarding
social and economic policies I have no
idea how to quantify that I mean you
know my views today are built on
essentially 20 years of following
politics and reading economics history
philosophy I I really couldn't say my
biggest inspirations I mean you know
that it's built on reading everything
from
you know 18th century philosophy and
ancient Greek philosophy - Angus Deaton
book on economic well-being written a
few years ago you know it's really
really tough and I wouldn't I at this
point it's hard to say any one or
another inspiration I mean I think the
framework I'm operating under overall is
I would be what I consider a left
libertarian social democrat in that I
want a compelling reason to have
government involved in endeavours and
there are compelling reasons to have
government involved in health care and
education
not so much in manufacturing airplanes
but the regulatory responsibility of
government is huge there I want people
to have as much freedom for
self-determination as possible and
government should be very involved in
setting those conditions but not going
beyond that in terms of determining what
jobs people should have or the the like
I mean it's it's a it's an interesting
question because it goes to my general
framework and at this point I've been
following all this stuff for so long for
you how that it's like that I couldn't
name like three people that have mostly
inspired me if that makes sense okay
yeah I was just wondering because um I
actually majored in economics and
marketing in my undergraduate studies
may I always feel like this kind of low
in like progressive voice are like
having this like progressive outlook I
guess amongst my peers and so it's like
I guess I'm more interested in learning
more about like economic policy whether
like whether it be progressive or more
conservative to like I guess about get a
better feel for to get a better feel for
my understanding of how I actually want
the government to function and yeah I
mean I think the problem with a lot of
economics departments in the u.s. is
that they teach a really narrow range of
stuff I mean I've said before I have no
problem with neoclassical economics
being taught and it's important to
understand that framework but when I
went to undergraduate University of
Massachusetts I died so
chillest Richard Wolffe was one of my
professors and I you know learned
Marxian economics and game theory and I
got into behavioral economics personally
after I graduated and it's most
economics programs are teaching far too
narrow a scope of material and it sounds
like that's sort of what you're
realizing yeah it's like it's like a
huge issue like I took environmental
economics like another local economics
collective actually went to Oxford
University and I noticed that a lot of
the framework was dealing with
neoclassical theory and how I was just
wondering how a little bit limited it is
dealing with negative externalities
arising from like things like pollution
or like some things about being
responsible for like we've managed and
things like a bad nature yeah I mean
neoclassical economics and market theory
fails to deal with fails to
appropriately deal with externalities
I'm actually reading it none of the
concepts are new but it's an interesting
book I'm reading naked economics by
Whelan is his last name I believe he
teaches at Dartmouth I forget his first
name and it has an entire chapter
devoted to how you need government
involved in markets because without it
the negative externalities are dealt
with only in that they are passed along
to somebody else and your your analysis
is exactly right all right I guess so
there might only questions thank you so
much for taking my calls
you're like a huge inspiration for me
because you do really kind of steal man
my progressive politics and Gotham
realities I can defend them a little bit
easier so I truly appreciate your voice
there please then have a good day okay
you too I so appreciate the phone call
thank you let's go to our caller from
the seven six zero area code who's
calling today from seven six zero seven
six zero maybe you're muted all right
and last opportunity four seven six zero
oh hello yes that's you
yeah I David okay so I just want ya can
you hear me alright yes I can okay I
just wanted to ask you what your opinion
was on the if you heard Minneapolis
recently are nine of the City Council
members announced that they would
disband the police department mm-hmm or
something like that
earth would vote on this what's your
opinion on that I'm not sure if you did
stigma in the past but I've not done a
segment on it I haven't seen the exact
proposal sometimes these proposals take
the shape of essentially separating the
police department into different units
or elements for lack of a better term
I'm not exactly sure what it is that
will actually be be made a reality if
such a reality takes place in
Minneapolis but I'm very interested in
seeing what it is that that they come up
with and you know there are other places
that sometimes are asserted to have
disbanded the police but really what
they've done is they've kind of
separated out some of the infrastructure
it's not not truly been disbanded in
what that might sound like like police
haven't been abolished but
responsibilities and super supervisory
authority has been rearranged and and
moved around so I'm interested to see
what Minneapolis comes up with yeah okay
was that it okay all right seems like
that caller that caller went bye-bye
let's go to our caller from the seven
one eight area code who's calling today
from seven one eight hey Greg from New
York first-time caller
hey Greg what's up libertarian I think
on some level you know I'm sort of more
on the libertarian side a little more
skeptical of the government institutions
including police and I just wanted to
say a lot of the progressive hosts are
sort of coming around to the
conversation that Liberty
you've been having okay let me stop you
right there Greg though because I need
to issue a huge disclaimer when I say
I'm a left libertarian I mean I'm saying
small-l libertarian right so if we
imagine a spectrum of authoritarianism
and libertarianism these are a lowercase
I my instinct is I want to be more on
the libertarian side unless there's a
compelling reason to regulator to
involve government so I am not at all
like not at all a capital L libertarian
I just mean that on issues of
authoritarianism versus libertarianism I
tend to lean towards the Liberty low
little L libertarianism unless there's a
compelling reason not to right I think
I'm the same way okay I just wanted to
push you a little bit on with my
skepticism of the government sure right
so for example just in the last few
months we've had everyone from the WH
o--'s at the CDC Surgeon General
including Falchi and including pence
saying don't wear masks and I believe
that that was a mistake
that led to the lock downs which were
supposed to be a last resort the
economic damage done from that and
people out of work now contributed to
these giant protests which of course the
police you know this has been going on
for years with the Ferguson protest and
then we had the Baltimore this has been
going on you know I am very skeptical of
having these authorities tell us don't
wear masks and then later saying yeah
you should wear masks and just
yesterday's w-h-o retracted what they
said which was that um Oh asymptomatic
people don't you don't spread the virus
but then they kind of walked it back
what you want why are we listening as
regular people who are living in the
world why don't we take things into our
own hands put things to put things into
the lobbies of buildings and solve it on
a private level okay so there's a couple
different guns going on here that are
interesting first of all you're rightly
pointing out that there have been
misunderstandings about the virus those
misunderstandings are not inherent to
government a agency
necessarily in other words lots of
people you also had you know people that
had nothing to do with government saying
we weren't gonna have any cases by the
end of April they had nothing to do with
government they were also very very
wrong so that part do you agree with
that that there were there were all
sorts of things that were incorrect
about the corona virus from industry
from private citizens from government
agencies from health organizations a lot
of people got a lot of things wrong you
agree
oh absolutely many people get things
wrong but when you centralize the
decision-making in the hands of the few
people that are wrong that's when it
gets really bad well my argument would
be that it's a contradiction that you
are on the one hand asserting your
skepticism of government power while at
the same time saying most of the
mistakes were not doing enough it's so a
lot of libertarians if presented with
the mandate from government very early
for everybody to wear masks would have
said I don't want that that's too much
power the government can't tell me to
wear a mask so I want you to think about
that contradiction you're saying you're
skeptical of government authority but
you're saying they weren't strict enough
but wouldn't you have been saying who
are they to tell me to wear a mask if
they had said that right away well it
could be clear I think there will be
government so anyway whether okay but
that wasn't but that was my question
Greg right well to answer your question
directly I'm saying that because we're
accustomed to listening to certain
authorities right word Authority would
imply that they have the authority in
the knowledge of it all so the fact that
we're comin to this versus let's say in
science or the English language and so
on I think that that we have to be very
careful when with the messaging that's
coming out from WH oh they were wrong
and and that's important too how are you
gonna put in filters so it doesn't
happen next time well so so I I agree
with you we have to this was a disaster
on all levels we have to have a better
you know more more well-functioning
system the pandemic response team never
should have been abandoned the pandemic
response PlayBook that was left behind
for Trump should have been followed but
remember we Trump didn't listen to the
w-h-o on a lot of stuff so at least in
the United States you said you're in New
York a lot of what went wrong here
doesn't really have as much to do with
the United States show we have a
government here that was led by an
incompetent buffoon so I don't want to
put the focus too much on the whu-oh
even though I agree with your critiques
Greg last thing I just wanted to say
look I live in New York and just look at
the sense of proportion
the NYPD is the seventh largest army in
the world by number of people yet
operate across several continents with
the war on terror and expanded budget
why not when I say defund right people I
think that's the wrong word many people
say you know disinvest or reduce the
budget yep the budget of the DoD that
can't account for seven trillion dollars
I mean at what point do we finally say
look conservatives we agree with you
let's start cutting and we will start
with DoD and the police force and give
to hospitals give to you know schools
why not yeah I I think one thing that
has been very much missing from this
entire discussion is we talked about
defunding and demilitarizing the police
what about defunding and demilitarizing
the military which is very rarely being
discussed right now and you know you
there's much more of a debate as to what
police departments are doing for us then
what 50 bases in Germany are doing for
us and I would agree with you Greg I
would like to see that be a bigger part
of the discussion thank you all right so
that's I just want to end with the word
of kudos or you know there's a lot of
people that don't embrace allies you
know across libertarians or
conservatives and you David I think are
out to talk about the truth and stick to
actually fact and I think there's a lot
of hope if everybody did that I think we
could find a lot of common ground all
right Greg thank you very much
appreciate the phone call and the kind
words that's gonna do it for calls today
sorry I wasn't able to get to everybody
but I do appreciate so many people
wanting to call in we'll take a quick
break and be back right after this
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com whether you're looking for
david pakman show coffee for your Chemex
or french press or a David Pakman show
t-shirt it's all available on our
website shipping to anywhere in the
world at david pakman.com slash gear
don't miss the bumper stickers to david
pakman.com forward slash gear the david
pakman show at david pakman.com
what will happen if Joe Biden defeats
Donald Trump in November and then you
get a two and a half or close to
three-month transitional period during
which Donald Trump is a very angry
lame-duck
that's the first question today in
audience questions David what do you
believe the transition period would look
like if Donald Trump loses so first of
all I love the question and I'm glad to
explore it but let's not get ahead of
ourselves we first need to vote and Joe
Biden first needs to win before we have
to concern ourselves with what a
transition period would look like first
of all in the immediate I would imagine
a delayed concession I think that if it
is very very close on election night
Donald Trump will not concede and if it
is a blowout Donald Trump may also not
concede under the guise that it's too
obviously fake Trump couldn't possibly
have lost by so much so I think
regardless of the results there's a good
chance Trump does not concede now just a
reminder about concession concession is
legally meaningless concession is a
formality it's done to show good faith
to signal the beginning of a peaceful
transition of power and it's norms and
conventions and all that different stuff
but the the concession legally speaking
is not relevant it is true however that
if for example a Republican concedes you
may see Republican secretaries of state
who might get much more involved in
challenging results with recounts or
whatever maybe not do it so while
legally not significant concessions can
still signal to governors and
secretaries of state around the country
how should you react and what should you
do next
so Trump will in in all likelihood it's
if it's close and it's likely to be
close and Trump loses Trump will likely
say he was cheated or that it was rigged
do we only have to look at 2016 remember
in 2016
Trump won and he still to this day
insists that the results were false and
that it was rigged against him because
losing the popular vote did not
sufficient sufficiently placate Donald
Trump's massive ego you will probably
see a few Republicans who would
or Trump and claiming that it was rigged
but my belief is that most Republicans
are going to largely accept the results
if indeed Joe Biden wins then I wouldn't
be surprised if during the transition
period Trump doesn't invite Joe Biden to
the White House this is a completely
standard thing that's done the Bush's
invited the Obamas the Obamas invited
the Trump's I wouldn't be shocked at all
to see Donald Trump break with that
convention as well but then what really
matters about the transitional period is
going to be what does Donald Trump try
to do legislatively and via executive
order and in terms of judges and
appointments and nominations and what
does he actually get done because a
lame-duck Trump that is furious that he
lost and believes it was rigged or
claims it was rigged is going to be even
more brazen and even more unscrupulous
than we've seen him be I would expect a
ton of executive orders some legal some
not legal I would expect pardons that
benefit him or his interests in some
direct or indirect way and I would
expect a scaling up a vicious vicious
attacks against his political opponents
if Republicans controlled the house and
by the way this is why this is so such
an important reason why the midterms
mattered so much when Democrats took the
house if Republicans controlled the
house you would have the risk of a
lame-duck Trump doing Wisconsin's style
legislation like when Scott Walker lost
the governorship in Wisconsin
Republicans in the legislature tried to
weaken the office of the governor for
the incoming Democrat to be able to do
much less if Republicans controlled the
house and Trump loses in November you
would likely see the same type of
attempt to limit the power of the office
of the presidency it's not going to
happen because Democrats took the house
in 2018 in terms of protests and
aftermath in terms of aftermath that
would include protests and unrest I do
think it depends on the margin of
victory I believe that a huge Biden
victory would set Trump off but that it
would really deflate the sales of the
Magga
people a narrow victory
will more credibly let Trump claim it
was rigged and I would absolutely expect
militia types patriot types etc to come
out and protest and there could be there
could certainly be violence and unrest I
do think that Mitch McConnell will keep
his eye on the ball and try to rapidly
get as many judges confirmed as possible
during a transition period for Trump
McConnell has been effective at doing
this legislation is unlikely again
because you need the house and the
democratically controlled house is not
going to give any big legislative
concessions to a lame-duck Trump that
they've just defeated so I would expect
a very messy November and December I
would expect lawsuits
maybe recounts and I don't think that
they will actually go anywhere if Joe
Biden wins over that transition period
media will start to ignore Trump more
and more and focus on who is going to be
in Biden's cabinet who from the from our
allies are coming back to the United
States and saying we welcome you we are
glad that Trump is leaving and that will
only further enraged Ahnold Trump if I'm
missing anything let me know
I've been getting a lot of emails from
people asking is Joe Biden a stronger
Challenger then Mitt Romney was in 2012
which was the last time we had an
incumbent president up for re-election
and I actually think that this may not
be the right question I think that this
is really more about is Trump a stronger
incumbent then Obama was in 2012 I I
don't think it's as much about the
challengers as it is about the
incumbents because the power incumbency
has power and it is arguably more about
the incumbent than it is about the
Challenger now we won't know until we
have the results remember that in 2012
Barack Obama won re-election with an
electoral landslide 332 to 206 with a
four percentage point popular vote win
this is really really big this is
possible for Biden or not or Biden could
lose depending on how the next five
months go so in thinking about
versus Obama as incumbents understand
that Trump's approval right now
depending on where you look it's 38 to
43 Obama at this point in 2012 was
around 48 so somewhere between 5 and 10
points higher approval for Obama at this
point in 2012 than for Trump right now
that's an important thing now Joe Biden
appears to have a slight lead in some of
the key swing states that Romney was
losing at this point in 2012 that's an
important difference to look at the
economic situation is a really big
factor because a lot of times
re-election campaigns are referenda on
referendums on the economy in May of
2012 we had about 8% unemployment right
now we have 16 percent unemployment now
it's unique in that a lot of it is
because of coronavirus but that's
something that we have to think about
one thing that is important from a math
standpoint is Obama could afford to lose
a bit in 2012 from where he was in 2008
and still could have won Trump can't
lose anything okay
Trump won by 77,000 votes across three
states that is very different than the
situation Barack Obama had in 2008 also
remember Trump lost the popular vote by
2 in 2016
Obama won by 4 when he was re-elected so
when you look at the margin that Trump
has even if Trump simply gets every vote
he had in 2016 and no more he likely
loses number 1 because the population
has grown since 2016 and number 2
because you are going to if you look at
the turnout in the primaries so far for
Joe Biden it seems that turnout will be
up so Donald Trump can't just hold every
vote from 2016 he needs to add something
in order to win and so far it's not
clear that that he has a path to doing
that so
the the the perspective I have is that
Trump is a weaker incumbent than Obama
was in 2012 and I believe that the
outcome in November is going to be much
more determined by that and the economic
circumstances then whether Biden or
Romney were stronger per se if you
disagree I definitely want to hear from
you
let's talk about taboos people writing
in and saying should politics and
religion be taboo and conversation with
significant others with family with your
significant others family at work etc so
the way I grew up was politics and
religion are just like any other topics
you talk about them with your family
your immediate family at larger family
gatherings with friends etc sometimes
there are disagreements sometimes there
are not but assuming nobody is espousing
some truly violent disgusting position
you talk about politics and religion
just like you do anything else and then
everybody's still friends and
everybody's still respectful and and the
like I actually now have an even
stronger position on this because online
discourse and social media expose people
to political discussion that is the
worst you can imagine I actually think
it would be particularly beneficial for
kids from a young age to be exposed to
discussions about politics and religion
that are respectful and that don't
devolve into personal attacks because
unfortunately if at home politics and
religion aren't being discussed if it's
school politics and religion aren't
being discussed
if wherever else they're not being
discussed and the model people have is
from Twitter we're really really screwed
and people end up not knowing how to
peacefully disagree with each other how
to respectfully express opinions that
aren't the same and then just to go back
to living with each other or working
with each other every disagreement is
seen as a personal attack people often
become triggered it's not good and we
all benefit from talking about our views
and we benefit from having them
challenged and we benefit from not
having topics be off-limits
now this doesn't mean you ignore decorum
or politeness or don't
use common sense right if you're on a
first date maybe you do talk about
politics or maybe you don't now very
often politics and religion can be the
difference maker whether two people are
compatible so maybe you do want to talk
about it right away maybe you leave it
for the second or the third date I don't
know if it's your first time meeting
your significant others parents maybe
you skip politics and religion that one
time not because you aren't comfortable
discussing it respectfully with whoever
but simply for for decorum and to avoid
disagreements in the interest of
establishing what hopefully will be a
long term relationship so use your
judgment don't you apply common sense I
think there's one other element of this
that's important to mention not only are
some topics taboo like politics and
religion but we also have a big deficit
of critical thinking skills and skills
with which we can examine our own
beliefs and how we came to our
conclusions and I think that if we want
to go in the direction of removing the
taboo around talking about politics and
religion where your quote not supposed
to we do need people who are better
informed about how to apply critical
thinking and basic epistemology skills
overall though I think we should be
doing more discussion of topics that
often become emotionally charged not
less and there has been no more
important time to be talking about
politics and religion and subjects that
can be difficult in all scenarios of
course again applying common sense if
you disagree let me know we've got a
great bonus show for you today get a
membership almost instantly by signing
up at join pakman.com